The Joe Rogan Experience when we talk
about what are the ideologies that drive
us the ideology of progress this is why
I have sometimes am skeptical not about
technology the Mastery and the Geniuses
that work in that field but how
technology and science as a subset of
our economic ideology can create exactly
the conditions that you're describing
and that journalist has exposed that if
your ideology permits that then what
kind of ideology is that what kind of
unconsciousness are we living in it's
not an Awakened Culture and all of the
discourse around like you know how we
treat one another as individuals and
progressivism culturally in domestic
territories hey people are should be
allowed to do this and that is all it's
a nonsense if that is permitted and not
only permitted required it's a
requirement you cannot have that
economic model without that price being
paid and as a culture whether it's me as
an individual or our entire culture
we've accepted that contract we've
accepted those terms well we we have in
some area areas of our life for sure you
know hopefully people haven't done that
in their interpersonal Intimate
Relationships but we certainly have in
the way we communicate with others we've
certainly accepted like very bizarre
ways of communicating online and
sometimes that bleeds out into real life
like where someone talks to people in
the real world as if they're on Twitter
and they get bashed like you see that
sometimes I think it's a it's a very
strange time where we I don't think
people have a a lot of faith right now
in institutions and I don't think they
have a lot of faith in Authority I don't
think they really believe that there is
someone who is wiser than them that has
a grand plan that's logical
that's that's workable where they're
looking out for all of us so I think
there's like a a feeling of chaos that
exists today that I don't think has ever
existed in my life like this before even
back during like the Bush Administration
when they thought you know everybody
thought Bush was a [__] they they still
thought
this is a good cabinet and they they
they're following all the checks and
balances even though they're probably
extracting too much money and they're
probably there's probably a lot of
cronyism and a lot of undercover deals
and a lot of like no bid contracts with
Halliburton and that kind of nonsense he
still thought they they have things
pretty under control it's a very solid
institution nobody believes that now you
see Pete bootage Edge and [__] Kamala
Harris and and Biden can't get a
sentence out you're like this is madness
these people are utter fools and these
are the people that are running
everything and these are the people that
are getting us on the brink of war with
Russia and I don't have any faith in
them and I think most people don't I
think you're right and when with the um
that era of the Cheney Bush wolf of its
rumsfelt he felt like oh these are the
Death Star buds guess what's happening
is there's this risen up military
industrial complex Rand Foundation
ideologues from the Republican right who
were the sanctioned baddies back in
those days are trying to uh yeah profit
from the colonization of of the Middle
East it's part of a new American project
we sort of understood it but you know
from where I'm coming from it was
somehow recognizable and a million
people went on a march to prevent that
war taking place because they knew there
were no weapons of mass destruction
which we now know to be the truth and as
you say now the figures that are in that
place are sort of posing as the good
guys like affable and avuncular
presidents and sort of friendly people
of like you know that across the
identitarian Spectrum that's meant to
feel inclusive and yeah they're wrapping
themselves up with Progressive identity
politics and then promoting a war yes at
the same time it's very wild yeah it
feels like a a mask and a veil like this
is what's interesting for me is as we
navigate this new and emergent space of
being able to prevent present counter
narratives oh and continually like all
of us now have like experienced oh
you're a right-wing conspiracy theorist
you've joined the alt-right you're a
gateway to this the darker all of that
language that grows up around it like
this and I've heard you speak about this
obviously a lot but the truth is that
who isn't sympathetic who anyone that's
got a family or love someone is
imperfected idea that people are going
to have various types of identity around
culture and religious expression and
racial expression and of this is a
conversation that the whole culture has
to be involved in together what my issue
is I don't think they believe in that
stuff I don't think they care I don't
think that they are creating an agenda
to advance the interests of vulnerable
people I think they are using it as a
distraction and a veil in order to carry
on with the same kind of corporate and
financial interests that have always
determined what the establishment is and
if there's one thing we can point to In
Our Lifetime is that the liberal
establishment has become co-opted by the
same forces that traditionally we
regarded the right to have been
corrupted by military industrial complex
financial industry yeah and there's now
like there's palpable evidence for that
and in order to not acknowledge that
that transition has taken place they're
able to keep the cultural conversation
going we care about your right to
express yourself and your identity
that's a way of not acknowledging we're
just the same we're pro-war and now when
there's that war you know like Jimmy
Dore and all those guys did that
anti-war March in Washington or whatever
it's like 5 000 people go now I don't
know if that's because of the last few
years and what the pandemic's done to
people accumulator and Gathering crowds
or whoever people have lost their the
belief and faith that people have any
can have any impact on politics anymore
there's just now this immersive sense of
apathy this as you say loss of trust in
in institutions and Authority but
something extraordinary has happened
when people that say that they're you
know we're the peace and love party are
the party that I advocating for war
won't include some of the complex
conditions that have led to this current
crisis which this clearly a case for
like you know NATO's infringement on
Russian territory the 2014 Coupe and I'm
not telling you anything you don't know
but like it's extraordinary that those
conversations don't happen right it's
like actually like the post-trump and
post-pandemic everything sort of enters
into that template there are certain
things you're not allowed to say now if
you sort of say did were Russia in any
way provoked is there any legitimacy to
this to their military uh to their
military actions from their perspective
that's the same as saying I don't think
you should take certain medications or
maybe aren't necessary and people aren't
it doesn't seem that the culture is
learning it doesn't seem that the the
the the the as the evidence is of
evolving that people are saying oh wow
look the stuff you were being told two
years ago now the things you couldn't
say online two or three years ago now
there's evidence for that in fact I've
bought documentation in case the
conversation went in this direction Joe
in my new position there's a legitimate
investigative journalist I've got actual
papers that I can show you from
conspiracy to fact